Ah ah ah
PlayStation 5
Size is 104 days in width Height is
390mm Depth 260mm By making it one size larger than ps 4, we
have realized a standard performance improvement in terms of processing power and quietness. With a
usb type c port on the front side  Ai speed usb compatible
5 a port
No side has 2 super speed usb compatible type a ports
lan port 1 year port
power terminal is installed
Front guard February is the intake port
Speaking of all discarded
Remove the base.
When you receive the Bach pair, it is fixed with a coin screw. The
removed screw will be revenge in the stand. Keep
this customer
fixed.
Please rotate.
Insert the base according to this mark.
The white panels on both sides can be removed by yourself upside down.
Lift the back corner
and slide it.
There is a built-in cooling fan here. The
video sucks in the representative air from.
psi If it falls
, dust catchers are installed in 3 places.
Dust collected in the last catcher can be vacuumed from the ends of these 3 places.  It can be sucked out. It
uses pcie 4.0 for future expansion storage. It
controls storage and occupant surgery.
From here, we will disassemble the PlayStation 5.
Red will occur
.
It controls 9 large fans of 45mm Ryoan.
Remove the face
th
Eh
ultra hd It is a drive unit of Blu-ray. The
live unit is completely a lot in the sheet metal case.
By mounting it with 20 insulators, it is 5 times at 0 o'clock.  It also defines the drive sound and
effort.
Next, disconnect the cable that leads to the stability of wi-fi 6 and bootus 5.1. Remove the
team version
.
Drives up to 2.23 ghz
and achieves 10.3 teraflops
Memory with 8 gddr 6
& width Maximum is 448 gb per second
Storage is changed to a 1 dd and implemented with 825 gb ssp large onboard
Castan is slowed down by ssb controller to
5.5 gb per second for raw data transfer speed and game load
time  The
esl soc runs a small large with a very high clock, so it
's not very expensive, such as picking buds on a silicon die.
In
ps 5, we adopted liquid metal for this equipment to achieve stable and high cooling performance for a long period of time.
We have been preparing to adopt this going minister for more than two years.
This is the heat sink of ps 5.
We use heat pipes that play ps 3 and ps 4, but
we have realized the performance of vapor chamber and toto by devising the shape and air flow.
This is the planned convenience bit of the character.
This is all the parts of the negative 0 positive heatsink
PlayStation